[موسيقى]
انا سهيله ابو عيشه
صاحبه البسطه هذه الي تلت سنين عليها
شغاله معمل جميع المشروبات الساخنه
[موسيقى]
فتحت عشان اترزق عليها
طعم اولادي محتاجش حدا يعني يعني مصروفات
الدار اجار الدار مثلا سقاطه وبحط في
النصيب وبنكمل من نجمع جاري الدار
[موسيقى]
والله العظيم هي من اهل الخير بنكرش بارك
الله فيهم هم جابوها وحتى عبوا لي اياها
كمان وقالوا لي شغل عليها وانا ولا كان
صعب علي اني اقف على بسطه ست يعني تعمل
شاي وجهها ولا هيك كان صعب علي بس والله
يجي بارك الله فيك
والحمد لله بيجوني والله من غزه من الشمال
عندي الحجه عند الحاجه
[موسيقى]
الله يخليك يا حجه بارك الله فيك يا حجه
يعني حاجه بتعجبني القهوه اكثر حاجه
القهوه سلم ايديك على القهوه يا حجه سلم
ايديك والله قهوتك زاكيه
نجيك من بعيد عشان اشرب الفنجان القهوه
عندك يا حاجه والله نسيتها لو جيت علي كان
عيطت علي
اجت مره اكثر موقف زعلت فيه وعيطت يعني من
قلبي جيت من في المنخفض منخفضها واقعه كل
اللي جواتها متكسر
قعدت عاد اعيطوا هيك اولاد الحلال رفعوا
لي اياه وحطيناها هنا
وعبيتها تاني صرت احلام الساقعه يعني
واجيب احلام حطه على رجلينا وبناتي
بس شغل والله كنا نولع نار
يعني ايش بس بدي اعمل بدي اكل كل ما بدي
اقول بدي ابطل بس بتذكر اولادي بقول
لاولادي مش مهم انا مش مهم انا كتير ناس
قالوا لي عظمك يا حاج الساقعه العظمك قلت
مش مهم كله فدا اولادي مش مهم
الله يجن معاي ورد علي يجي من الساعتين
يجي نفتح ونزبطه ونسخن مي ويجوا الناس
بالسيارات
يروحوا يلبس البوت العجال البنات ويروحن
يشرب قهوه يرجع تاني اعمل لهم انا المشروب
واحنا الصينيه ويروحن لحد هنا يروحن والله
[موسيقى]
اعيش في بيت ملك نفسي نفسي